like a murderer from the past like
Genghis Khan or something like that well
you actually get in trouble now for
cultural appropriation you know where
you wouldn't get in trouble
is it the Renaissance Fair when they
have like heroes and villains day comes
on what you're doing
you got some squinty eyes right now
we're taking it too far but why is it
weird that a physical characteristic
like eyes like small eyes is like
offensive to discuss is that fascinating
it is fascinating but to recreate I
think is it offensive or is it people
enjoy the feeling of being offended I
think there's a there's a sweet spot in
the middle there I would beg to differ
that some of the people in society who
are offended by words term sentences
aren't necessarily truly offended as
much as they want to say they're
offended I am a hundred percent on board
with you
so loser doctor Peluso sorry thank you
doctor Peluso I have HPV pH i I can't I
mean people get offended they love it
offended and you know what they also
love doing not doing shit about it but
in their defense if you see like a movie
where a dude is playing an Asian man
mm-hmm but he's a white dude and they do
some malarkey with his eyes like
motherfucker I use that special-effects
monarchy and change them into a Chinaman
oh god damn leprechaun that fucker you
could be an Englishman no one has a
problem with calling someone an
Englishman but you call someone a
Chinaman no no whoa you're getting weird
there it's just getting weird
it's exhausting when people are offended
and then it's like girls being offended
in writing articles about guys that are
doing me two moments but they're not
going to the rallies they're not
involved in the community they're not
really like moving the needle they're
just screaming is it good to go to
rallies I think it's good to be all
so actively and physically involved in
whatever movement you believe in I think
just saying and posting it on Twitter is
a facade but it's good for likes you can
get a lot of likes boom I mean I guess
there's some eyeballs on it you're
you're creating a conversation but I
don't know I just believe in like living
walk in the talk a little bit more what
the fuck were we just talking about that
is Oh Chinese actors that get fucked out
of roles by white people they don't do
that anymore but they used to yeah one
of the big ones was Charlie Chan Charlie
Chan was like a famous detective show
remember that show was it but was it
casted as a white man it was a white
dude playing a Chinese detective that
was like super wise detective that's
busted but he looks like like a white
guy who eats good like a cock more like
commish no like that's that's my holy
hell yeah that was Charlie Chan I'm
offended yeah you should be he looks
more like he looks like a shitty
magician he looks like Chewie from The
Comedy Store you don't you guys don't
remember Chewie that is offensive
the same thing happened with them let me
see that picture look at that that shit
is ridiculous I can't happening there
he's he looks like he runs a casino in
upstate New York
you ever hear him talk can we play
someone I need to hear it from Charlie
Chan it was very offensive oh my god
dunt dunt Charlie I'm shook right now
what's that Jamie what do you think he
went what year do you think this was
1945 it says he doesn't say 50s Scarlett
Johansson had that whole issue remember
she was cast in that movie and it was
supposed to be an Asian role yeah and
how and people went crazy oh shit bailed
she bailed let's hear some of those who
he goes I can't you contact mysterious
mr. Oz sure became a family got off the
train and
that he and I have trailed him for seven
hours Rosie no you follow you they
couldn't help it I figured you were part
R&R our show we've kept close to it
look in his face he doesn't even look
remotely they taped his eyes for sure
they did some weirdness but not much
because he looks like every housewife
and Bev Hills - the facial hair the
pulled back face were you like take off
ten years
but back then you know this guy could
get away with that you know uh
what's-his-face lady in the saran wrap
she's a ghost or some shady dude what's
happening to her that is bizarre you
know if they had saran wrap put your
food inside of it she's wearing like a
glass veil is it Shia LeBouf and Shia
LeBouf their time travelers this is I
mean isn't it great to live in this time
where our movies are so much better but
we're gonna laugh in the future looking
back at how stupid things are today you
just can't see it coming
never when you thought the look at that
guy that's a cool chair what is that
dude so another Chinese guy that dude
this is not really a Chinese guy I think
he's got that's some terrible face
makeup I think added to him I think that
looks like a like Joey Diaz on acid look
at that with a head wrap that's family
tape it does look like tape a regal tape
really angry ruling a kingdom after a
couple divorces yeah he's like an 80
year old tape yeah that's amazing well
that's what they used to do look look up
John Wayne as Genghis Khan that's even
dumber even man didn't even change
anything including the way talked he
talked like John Wayne we're gonna go
out there we're gonna fuck up these
Russians
he talked literally like John Wayne but
he was dressed like a Ferb fucking hat
on so dumb oh my god you ever see it yes
how when they made that movie where
they're like this is it this is it yeah
they didn't know everything sucked I'm
everything did kind of suck there's only
a few like gone with the wind like whoa
what did they do they're a few movies
Citizen Kane whoa like wow this one
doesn't suck yeah yeah yes God I mean
the likeness is a little amazing to wait
oh you imagine look at that beard like a
fucking sheriff and some wide west Wild
West Town to Genghis Khan Hollywood was
so whitewashed it really really was well
they knew back then if they did a John
Wayne movie they would sell a million
tickets you know it's that's really what
the but the thing is I mean an aspect of
that is still going on go on